Hey, I'm Chad. I boom, rod. Hi, I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is Radiolab and today
we begin on a plane. Thank you Brooke,
which carried our newly married
producer Tim Howard to the Galapagos.
So I took the plane from Quito.
We had just finished the honeymoon
that morning. They got up
[inaudible] they make announcements
and at a certain point the flight
attendants,
they open up all of the overhead bins
and they walk up and down sprayings some
sort of insecticide
for what? For like, uh,
invasive species I think. Yeah,
like whatever bugs might've
snuck out in the brain.
But at this point I'm
getting super excited and I'm
thinking about Darwin and I
start reading voyage of the Beagle,
his book on this new book that
I had bought for the trip,
but then my power supply
didn't work and my nook died.
That was a big problem for Darren
to run out of power, his book. Okay.
And then the islands come into site.
What is the color of the Pacific Ocean
when you look at the plane window?
That was actually the first thing
I noticed. It's this totally wild,
like I've never seen
like this storybook blue,
green iridescent aqua marine
and I, I'm thinking like, wow,
this is going to be like dropping
into another world, you know,
like nature in its purest form.
My version was is my dream of what it
would be like is you land on it and it
sort of like low grassy knoll
and an enormous turtle comes by.
The one that you could
sit on the top of it,
it wouldn't notice that you were there
just going to meet to the airport just
wandering by and that it's
very similar to to what I was
picturing, but maybe I
need [inaudible] to land.
We take the 40 minute
bus ride to play Yarra
[inaudible] our Toyota, which
turns out to be kind of a big town.
Tons of people live there. Oh, it's
like a fishing village. Tons. No,
it's way bigger than a fishing village.
And just let me say that my first hours
in Galapagos work totally different than
I was expecting.
I'm sort of the first thing
that really just like,
where the hell am I?
I am walking through the towns kind
of late Sun is just starting to set,
I'm actually walking down
Charles Darwin Avenue,
just kind of getting the lay of
the land when all of a sudden
[inaudible] this line of cars comes
around the corner honking endless honking
and waving flags, blue flags. At first
I didn't know what that was happening,
but turns out it was an election
and I was just really blown away that
this continued this procession for like 15
minutes.
And I remember asking one guy who's gonna
be up though, they're driving so slow,
I can just walk up to them, go and say,
I've got it up. I sold car. I'm like,
who's your candidate? And they're like,
I didn't know who the guy was, but
it turns out he was the incumbent.
And I'm like, is he gonna win? And this
guy he like doesn't even say anything.
He just kind of points you like points
at the cars in front and behind as if
like, dude, seriously. You
see how many of us there are?
But then at a certain point I noticed
this one guy by himself standing on the
sidewalk wearing a white shirt
and jeans. He's waving a flag,
but his flag is a different color.
It's white and it's really loud.
But I go up to him and I yell at
him, who's your candidate? He said,
I am a candidate. And I'm like,
what are you kidding? Seriously.
So his name is laminate
[inaudible] [inaudible]
he is a naturalist guide.
You actually ended up meeting a lot of
people employed that way in Galapagos and
he tells me [inaudible] outsider
politica politically speaking,
he's an outsider.
And of course I'm wondering why he's
standing there by himself waving a flag at
this entire parade of people
who don't support him at all.
And he tells me cl
moment, well I'm nervous
[inaudible] if the party in power now
the front runners, if they get elected,
they
[inaudible] [inaudible] and I
see a dark and uncertain future.
The hotel is more big hotels,
more of these enormous boats,
more people [inaudible] and
if things keep going this way,
who's going to stand up for nature?
This is Radiolab and we are dedicating
the entire hour to this little set of
islands. And to that question,
as the world is filling up with
more and more and more people,
is it inevitable that
even the most sacred,
pristine places on the planet
will eventually get swallowed up?
And how far are we willing to go to return
a place to what it was before we got
there? And more importantly,
can we, oh, I'm never a
doubter. Okay, so this is Linda.
Linda Caio currently the science
advisor for Galapagos Conservancy.
I began my work in Galapagos in 1981
she first came to study tortoises back
then. You know, Galapagos
was really isolated,
barely any cars, super
limited electricity.
All I remember is having a smile on
my face all the time because you know,
as a biologist going to
Galapagos is like going to Mecca.
[inaudible]
she says you have islands with
massive volcanoes, forests,
tree ferns that grow, you know,
well above a human's height.
Yeah, I mean powerful
colors. You know, there's
green mangroves, black flower
flows and pink flamingos.
This is Mathias Espinosa and naturalist
guide in Nicola was in like Linda,
he says that when he first got to the
Galapagos in the 80s he couldn't believe
that the place was real
to his breast taken.
He visited an island called Fernandina
and the first thing they saw was a of
fluid was moving
[inaudible].
Yes. What's what's going on, you know?
No, no, that's not the lava flow.
This is like 1000 seat
Iguanas taking a sunbath
and he says he would go on these dive.
Can you imagine
the school itself,
how the head checks like 500 800
passing in front of you like tuna?
I mean like, like sardines.
It shows you the power.
It shows you all for evolution.
There is revolutions, varies child.
Okay, so quick context,
a Galapagos islands cluster of islands
way off the coast of Ecuador in the
Pacific, 19 bigger islands, bunch of
smaller ones. And this is the place,
of course,
we're Darwin landed in 1835 and
as he went island to island,
he started noticing that there were
all of these creatures that were really
similar to each other, but
also a little bit different.
The tortoise's had different shells
depending on the kind of island they lived
on. The finches look similar,
but their beaks were always a little bit
different. And this gets him thinking,
what if it isn't the way
that everybody always says?
What if God didn't create every single
species in the beginning and leave them
unchanged? What if in fact
life is purely change?
What if everything has
been changing all the time?
Darwin's five weeks on Galapagos push
him to develop his theory of evolution.
And that's also why when
we think of evolution,
we think of the Galapagos
and in particular
we think of two iconic
creatures, the tortoise
and the finch.
Let me start by telling you about
the tortoise. It's hot, it's bright.
It's such a perfect day for tortoise.
Something are not hunting. But you know,
looking for fourth day I was there. Um,
I went to the island of Floriana,
which Darwin visited and they're up in
the highlands basically in the middle of
this yard. Oh my God.
There are these three massive tortoise's
just clustered together under a tree.
Wow. That is freaking amazing.
Describes them. What do they look like?
These are such alien looking creatures.
They're like the size of, Jeez,
I don't even know what they're massive.
They look like they would
crush you to death. Well,
now how many years these
guys have been here for?
They can live for over 150 years. Wow.
[inaudible] is trying
to get over a branch.
[inaudible]
who is that? That is the
sound of a tortoise breathe.
That's cool.
So, uh, Linda,
when she first went to Galapagos to
study these [inaudible] is about 30 years
ago. I did a trip where we
backpacked around the Caldera.
She took a trip to this island called
Isabella hiked up the side of a volcano
and looked at all the tortoise country
and it was an impenetrable forest,
basically tortoise heaven.
And what makes it so perfect
for tortoise's is in the
dry season in Galapagos
that go Roula, which is a very, very
thick mist, comes onto the island.
It rolls over this forest and it
catches in the branches of the trees.
The water then drips down from the top
of the trees down to the ground creating
what we call drip pools,
which provides tortoises with
water during the dry season.
And they liked to rest in water.
And so there under the trees you have
these ponds with dozens of Torrid's domes
just rising out of the water.
So that was my first experience. It
was a magical, magical area. And then,
um,
I actually didn't get back there for
maybe 15 years from when I was there the
first time.
And when I returned that
forest was 100% gone.
The drip pools were just
dry dust bowls. Wow.
There was no shade tortoises where
we're sitting out in the sun or,
or crowded around the couple of
stalks that were still there.
This is Carl Campbell.
I work for island conservation and I'm
based here in the Galapagos Islands.
Carl's actually the guy who showed me
those tortoises. Um, it was just a, yeah,
it was a barren landscape.
Yeah. Barron Barron grounds.
What happened to the forest? Um,
goats.
Goats. That was definitely not what
I thought you were going to say.
I thought you were gonna say people,
it was kind of a collaboration.
So here's the story.
Goats were originally sort of brought
to the Galapagos and probably by pirates
and wireless back in the 15 hundreds.
You had tons of sailors making these,
these long voyages across the Pacific.
And uh, Galapagos was, you know,
the major port on, on the
whaling route, um, where yeah,
you'd come and get fresh
water, but you'd also, uh,
come in and pick up a tortoise's plan
tortoises and boats and take away several
hundred of them often and turn them
upside down and they can last for up to a
year and a half.
Shit, like lying there upside down. Yeah.
Lying there upside down in order
to make space for the tortoises.
The whalers and pirates would often take
goats that they brought with them and
throw them onto the islands.
That way when they're on their way
back and sick of eating tortoises,
they could grab those goats.
So whalers and Buccaneers,
they introduced goats to Galapagos,
but on islands like Isabella,
which is this massive
island size of Rhode Island,
the goats were actually penned in to just
a little part of it because there was
this black lava rock that ran across
the island stream, Lee rough lava,
that's extremely difficult to
walk across 12 miles of it.
So that had acted as a barrier
basically with goats on one side,
tortoises on the other.
But according to Linda,
some sometime in the late
1970s the goats got brave.
We were probably talking just a few goats,
but by the 1990s those few goats,
the population had exploded and you
just about a hundred thousand goats.
And if you think of 100,000 goats
eating everything in their path,
every sort of plant that even the bark
off of trees, they destroy the forest.
So now they had a dilemma. On the
one hand, the tortoise's needed help.
On the other hand,
you had all of these goats that didn't
choose to be on the island. You know,
it wasn't their fault. And the goats
that were out there were gorgeous.
You know, they had curled horns, different
colored fur, just beautiful animals.
And they'd been there for 500 years.
Some people were concerned, you know,
with the goats have their own sort of,
if you will, right to be there. Those
arguments came up frequently. Do,
which Carl would respond. Yeah. Are we
going to let tortoise's go extinct? Yeah.
There's thousands of islands around
the world that have goats on them.
These tortoises are only found
here. So where do your values lie?
[inaudible]
and so in 1994 we had what we called
the tortoise summit in England.
And that was where we started the
discussions about what are we gonna do?
Experts came from all over
the world. Linda says,
we want to get rid of the goats.
And many of them thought we were
nuts and that it was impossible.
There's 100,000 of them. So many doubters.
Carl says he even heard the idea,
why don't you put lines?
Yeah, they eat, go and see in Africa.
Yeah, why don't you get lines on there?
And those are really interesting ideas,
but at some point they're going to get
hungry and they're gonna start eating all
the other things that you know, you
treasure bike, the occasional tourist.
In any case, after endless planning
and meetings took eight years,
I think they commence
project Isabella.
So the helicopters we used,
they're [inaudible] MD five hundreds
small helicopter there for four passengers
with one pilot, single
turbine, five blades.
This is phrased phrase a Sutherland.
I was the engineer pilot and sharp shooter
2004 through to 2006 almost everyday.
During that time, Frazier
would fly over Isabela island.
Two guys with two shooters are the
side of the helicopter. What you do is,
so you come across when you're flying
along and you might see one guy says he
followed that goal, does it
ran away till join its friends?
Do you have to find all those
other guides circled real low?
You'd fly around them, around them up,
try and get them in with a single grape,
and then
you start picking off the
goats one by one by one.
And there are actually videos online
where you see these packs of goats running
for their lives and then
dropping to the ground.
The last goat or two might sort of run
into a area where it's impossible to
reach, oh actually go into
caves.
And what would do is would find a location
as close as we could or ride on top
of the cave,
drop out one of the two shooters that
was in the helicopter and he'd physically
go into the cave shoe,
the goats out or shoot them on site.
And then you go on and actually in
under a year through this aerial attack,
they end up wiping out 90%
of the goats on Isabella.
But to give an example of the nature
of this business, that's Josh Donlin.
He runs an NGO that was
involved in project Isabella.
It's relatively easy to remove 90%
of a goat population from an island.
But as they become rare and rare,
they're harder and harder to detect.
The goats become quote,
educated. They learn that
sound means
so the goats start hiding.
So they'll go onto bushes,
they won't move to learn to stand
under a tree, holding their breath.
And so you end up flying around
and an expensive helicopter,
not finding an it goes. Now the way we
deal with that, it's an interesting one.
We use this technique
called Judas goats. Yeah,
Judas goats. Initially it was,
Carl's suggestion was goats, uh,
gregarious and like being in groups.
They're herd animals, right? And so,
uh, the technique that we would
use was you would fire them,
the helicopter, you fly around, you'd
find some goats, you capture goats,
capture them, lie, and then
come back back to base camp.
Offload Dan and
we put a radio collar on him and
you throw them back on the island
and then you wait.
Instinctively that lone guy will
go and find out the goats. A week.
Two weeks go by, you fire up the
helicopter, they get back over
the island with this little
device. It's a directional antenna.
Start Tracking the Judas go fill. They
spot it with some other goats and then
everyone gets shot except the
Judas go there. [inaudible]
go finds more friends and then
everyone gets shot except the Judas go.
And then they do it again.
Everyone will get shot
except the Judas go.
And you do that every two
weeks for a year. Oh my God.
And that is how they
go from 90% go free to 91 to 92 to 93
to 94 just like having a pogrom on you
over and over and over
again. Jesus, it gets worse.
Now Judas Goat is a good Judas goat until
it gets pregnant cause then it doesn't
want to be social anymore.
It goes off and has this
kid and is very solitary,
which is the last thing you want when
you're trying to get goats off islands.
So Carl kept mulling this problem.
What would it take to basically make,
you know, the the perfect year disco,
the Ideal Judas goat, if you will.
Um,
is it goat that would search for and be
searched for and that would never get
pregnant.
So curl Campbell figured out a technique
where we could sterilize them in the
field.
It grabbed the goats Darden and then in
a matter of minutes SnipSnap did you do
this? Yeah. Well I, I stood next
to Karl and watched him do it
and Carl took it one step further and
he actually gave these females hormone
implants, basically put them in
the heat for an extended duration.
Normally a female goat would be in
heat for maybe a couple of days.
These females would go for more than
190 days. And wherever they went,
they would lower those male goats out
of their caves. So that, you know,
all in all over the course
of this two year program,
we had hundreds of Judas goats
out and using those goats,
they were able to go from 94%
goat free to 96 to 97 to 98.
And basically when you have only Judas
goats meeting up with other Judas Coats,
then you can say the goats have been
eliminated, that you're down a point.
They got to, at least
on Isabella in mid 2006,
uh,
this kind of eradication program was
far beyond anything that anyone had ever
done anywhere in the room
because it turns out they weren't just
doing this on Isabella island. No,
we're talking about island by island.
Over the course of about seven years,
they eliminate over 250,000 goats.
[inaudible]
so you, um,
you complete that with
Isabella and did it work?
Yeah. The results of this
were absolutely impressive.
You had plants re-emerging you had
trees growing back and in a really short
period of time and this allowed for
those important drip pools and tortoises,
they basically got their home back.
[inaudible]
this is a real thing.
Tortoise's walking around
[inaudible]
same craven. So they did
it. They got all the goats,
not all the goats. What do
you mean there's Judas goats?
They kept them around. Why? I would just,
I would've shot them first out of
sympathy for them. Yeah, exactly. Well,
they needed the goats because, well
there was the problem of people
[inaudible]
because during the 90s these
demonstrations started.
That happened.
Demonstrations. So outrage
and violent activities.
Yeah.
Constant conflict to explain
[inaudible] [inaudible] this is
Augustine Lopez, longtime fisherman.
And he told me that in
the 70s and eighties
[inaudible] lobster was fished all
year round. Have you have it yet? Okay,
no restrictions.
And then fishermen started making a
killing fishing sea cucumber because there
was this huge demand. But then
the national park comes in,
same group that's doing the
goat eradication and they
tell the fisherman they're
overfishing, the sea cucumber.
They've got to limit their catch.
And the fishermen are like, who are you
to tell me that I can't feed my family?
So they lash out.
[inaudible]
they marched down Charles Darwin Avenue.
They would come down the street throwing
rocks and sticks and everything.
And that's Paul Watson, founder of this
East Shepherd Conservation Society.
He was there counter protesting,
and he says that at one point they went
after national park buildings and they
were attacking the ranger stations with
Molotov cocktails. They blockaded roads.
They literally drove the Rangers out of
the National Park headquarters and took
it over on Isabella. They burned down
a building, the kidnap some people,
including some of my crew. And
they even killed dozens of towards
it says slitting their throats
according to some accounts.
They even hung them from trees. Uh, so,
but not only that, but
according to Linda, those goats,
couple islands where they've been
eliminated, fishermen have put them back.
Really? Oh yeah.
And so what they decided to do is leave
the Judas goats on various islands where
they can live out their sterilized
days, chomping on grass,
sharing war stories until such time
as they might be needed. Again.
It, the F is the war between the Greens
and the and the fisherman and Sochi.
Is that still hot and difficult
and are they still, you know,
killing tortoises and they're
not the fishermen? Um,
they seem to have stopped, you know,
taking over national park and
killing tortoises to know why it,
it's a combination of
reasons. On the one hand,
fishermen have started to participate
in the actual fisheries management more
cause it seems like they realize if
they're going to keep their livelihood,
they can't just fish everything
out. But then at the same
time the tourism economy has been taking
off. And so all of these fishermen,
they find that it's easier for them to
actually survive by using their boats,
um, to take tourists
around island to island.
So they're all kind of converting
over into the tourism economy.
We're going to take a short
break. This is Radiolab.
We'll be back with producer Tim Howard
and this hour on Galapagos in just a
moment.
Hi, this is Linda Caio.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
National Science Foundation and the
elephant piece,
one foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and technology.
In the modern world.
More information about Sloan
and www@wwwdotsloan.org
Sloan dot or hi Joe and
this message.
Radiolab is supported by swell
investing and impact investing platform.
What have you got invest in our planet
while also investing in your financial
future? Think about that. Our
resources are diminishing.
Our population is growing.
Companies solving today's biggest
challenges will be tomorrow's leaders.
Swell helps you invest in high growth
companies working towards clean water,
renewable energy, and green technology.
It's a market opportunity
you can feel good about.
Get a $50 bonus when you open your
account@swellinvesting.com slash Radiolab
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and this hour,
well the honeymoon's over Galapagos.
This is the place where Darwin began to
develop his theory of evolution and it's
the place 170 year or maybe, Eh,
180 years later where our producer Tim
Howard landed wearing fishnets in a bad
brains tee shirt to find,
to find a very different
landscape than what Darwin saw.
And we just told you a story about how
far humans are willing to go to protect
something. This next part,
it's about how far we're willing to go
to get something back that we've already
lost to sort of restore a place and
a creature to its quote. Wild state.
This story unfolds on one of Galapagos
is most northern islands where they also
had to get rid of some goats.
Oh, it's called Pinta. Pinta.
Pintos was a very special
place. This is James Gibson,
professor of conservation biology
at the State University of New York.
It's a one of those islands. It's not
part of any tourist visitation site.
So there are no people there. And
uh, when you set foot first on Pinto,
you immediately sense sure
[inaudible] birds
problem is on pin a, things
were spinning out of control.
The vegetation was growing wild,
the forest was getting overgrown
with the wrong kind of plant.
And the whole ecosystem was
just teetering out of balance.
And one of the reasons for this,
according to Linda Coyote is that
we had an island with no tortoises
because tortoises are
sorta like the lawn mower.
You know, they, they plow down
vegetation, disperse seeds,
but for centuries had been hunted
by those whalers. And in about 1906,
the pinto tortoise went
extinct. 1906 yeah,
a little over a hundred years ago.
They don't know the exact date,
but then one evening in March of 1972
yes, this fellow pizza, she h partook.
He's a well known tortoise researcher.
He was on Santa Cruz island having
dinner with some friends and we got to
chatting about tours. And one of the
people he's eating with says, Hey, uh,
I was recently on Pinna island
collecting snails and I saw this tortoise
and I thought, do you
know what you have done?
[inaudible] a hundred years.
He in some National Park Rangers race
out to Pinta and there was this beautiful
shoulders, one male
tortoise, maybe 50 years old.
They weren't sure they'd eventually
name Him George Lonesome George.
But at the time the immediate
question was, are there any more?
Because if they could find a female
for George, then they could, you know,
maybe de extinct the species.
So I poked around in the areas where
we've got the one and I found a shell of a
female dead animal. Oh, it won't happen.
Well, how had, how had this
female toward his died?
Uh, someone chopped it in half. No,
you see the marks where
it was just chopped up.
I felt violent. I wanted
to borrow someone's gun.
I'd gone kill the person.
Everyone held out hopes for just
finding more tortoises back.
James says they kept going back and
combing the island with highly trained
tortoise sniffing dogs. But
in the end there was just,
George then shifted the
focus on, now what do we do?
We then went to a wolf volcano island
next door and collected two females,
two females that sort of looked like
George but weren't quite the same species.
And we put them with George to
see if we could get him to breed.
He never did
well. It's an interesting, so they
thought, hmm, maybe he needs a pinto lady.
So now of course there are no female
tortoises on Pinta, but they thought,
you know,
maybe a zoo somewhere or
private collection has one
cause you really never know.
So they called around,
offered huge cash rewards.
People sent in dozens of tortoises.
But Linda took one look at them
and was like, no, no, no, no,
they weren't Pinterest.
So then they thought we've got to
take matters into our own hands.
Basically what you do is you sit at the
back of the tortoise and first you have
to get to where they'll allow you to
touch them. Um, and eventually you start,
um, you know, fondling their,
their legs and tails and,
and hoping to get them to ejaculate
and had a volunteer working with me.
Her name was viva greed,
Gianni. She worked with
him every other day or so for a few
months and was never successful.
We were really starting to get
kind of desperate about options.
And James says, in a way it was a
paradox because on the one hand, awesome,
we have an actual living Pinta island
tortoise. But on the other hand,
he might've actually been like the
worst possible candidate for last of his
kind. He seemed to really
like to keep to himself.
He never really liked
other tortoises much.
He didn't seem to like humans
and maybe that's why he survived.
He wasn't curious. Yes. James says a lot
of tortoises, they hear your footsteps,
they raise their heads,
they come out to see what's going
on and then they get whacked. Yeah.
In any case, for about 40 years,
scientists tried everything
humanly possible to get loan,
some George to meet with another tortoise
so they could resurrect the species
and bring Pinta island back to
its original state. Nothing worked
until
one day in July of 2008 George turns
to the two female tortoises that he had
been ignoring for years and he says
inexplicably, he just suddenly
decides to me with both of them,
they each lay eggs.
Two clutches were ultimately laid in
his corral and the scientists are like,
doc George got our hopes up dramatically,
but they ultimately were infertile.
Mother
mid eighties they were having a meeting
about this. That's conservationist.
Josh Donlin again,
whole bunch of herpetologists were out
there and some island conservationist and
they're talking about what to do
Pinta and they can't get one of them,
George to reproduce,
which we were hoping to do because then
they could build a Pinta population and
put it on Pinta and he says that as
the meeting wore on, it got tense. Oh,
for sure. In fact, one guy spoke
Harry Green,
I'm a professor of ecology and
evolutionary biology at Cornell University
said that at this meeting there was
one guy who just couldn't take it.
Oh, all I remember is him just fuming.
He sat there getting more
and more and more frustrated.
Then finally he just blurted out,
shoot that tortoise and
uh, quit wasting our time.
[inaudible]
because in his view, this,
the single individual was holding up
this huge conservation [inaudible]
and of course the shock was there was
a way went around the room when he said
that.
I recall seeing sort of second wave as
the Spanish translation of passed around
the room.
And really what that guy was specifically
saying was, don't be precious.
A tortoise as a tortoise, as a tortoise.
Let's just take some tortoises from a
nearby island and put them back on Penta,
but there's a much bigger question
here that that goes way beyond globe
[inaudible],
which is basically like, what is
the right way to protect nature?
Now people are right now
throwing beers at each
other around what is the right strategy.
[inaudible]
Josh says that there are basically
two camps right now on the one side,
you've got this classic,
like what you might call Eden
approach conservation biology.
It's foundation is this idea of pristine
wilderness from the very beginning.
I think all of us, well, I can't
speak for other people, but,
but you always have this idea of wanting
to get it back to some kind of pre
human condition.
Every human being the operative
word. And, and if you think about it,
we all have this. We all have this,
this picture of what we want
to bring it all back to,
you know what might be like, oh,
the planes just covered with buffalo, or,
or maybe the Serengeti desert
with lions and elephants,
or maybe it's 10,000 hammerhead
sharks, but whatever the scene is,
it just doesn't have any people.
But is carrying that idea,
those pictures of your head
even like youthful anymore.
It's like so Sanuk no, but
it just seems so unrealistic.
Right? But I mean, in the bigger picture,
you can make the argument that humans
now affect every square meter of the
earth.
There's no place, no matter how remote
we get, you can go to the North Pole.
It's been affected by human
activity. You can go, I don't know,
the depths of the impenetrable jungle.
It's been affected by human activity.
That's how they dream is
she's an environmental law
professor at the Berkeley
School of law in California. You're
radically remaking the world.
And the question is,
what's our responsibility?
And this brings us to our
second school of thought,
which in its most extreme version goes
something like this. We're God. Yeah,
we might as well get good at it.
And we're going to have to create these
ecosystems based on our best science.
And you could argue we're going to have
to get a whole lot better at making some
very, very difficult decisions.
Climate change seems to mean that a
lot of species are pretty much doomed,
30% 40% 50% of the species now on
the planet in a few decades maybe
disappearing.
And this is what I think is really the
tough question now is if we can see EAD
that we can't any longer
save all the species,
then does that put us in the situation
of having to decide which ones we'll save
and which ones we won't?
And do we have any basis for
making those kinds of decisions?
Hmm.
So you're saying that the, that the
club, let's go back to when it was good.
Let's go back to a better
time. That's just silly.
I didn't say it was silly. Okay. What
did you yeah, I said it was impossible.
Thinks might not be silly.
They might not be stupid ideas,
but we still might not be able
to do them. Okay. So here's, um,
a
plaque.
It says lonesome George is the last
survivor of the dynasty of land.
Tortoise is from Pinta island.
And in fact in 2012 after
decades of trying to get him to,
to Breed
[inaudible]
lonesome George Dies r I p 24th of June,
and the [inaudible] went
extinct. So damn case in point,
I guess no, going back. Yeah,
I mean that's what I thought.
But then I spoke with this woman. Hello.
Hello. Just tell it. Do you hear me?
Yes, I do. Who kind of
scrambled everything up for
me. Can I get you to, um,
introduce yourself? Yes.
My name is [inaudible].
I am a senior research scientist at
Yale University. And just tell us,
come up with kind of a radical
idea. I call it the Phoenix project.
Here's the backstory.
In the mid nineties we started in 94 to
Cielo and some folks from the Galapagos
National Park, they began taking a census
of all the tortoises in the Galapagos,
the population of tortoises
on all the islands.
They were going to do this
big population studies.
So they went island by island,
took a little bit of blood from
all these different tortoises,
did a genetic analysis and Oh,
pla found something they never expected.
A group of tortoise is not on
Pinta that had a lot of Pinto
DNA. I remember very clearly. That
moment was very, very exciting.
It's like, yes, look at this. Yeah.
Wait, you're saying this Pinta DNA was
on a nother island? Yeah. None on Pinta.
No. Well, how would that happen?
Um, we don't think it was natural.
Just Ella thinks it might've
been the whalers made.
They're the whalers or the pirates,
you know,
because like we talked about in the
1718 hundreds these whalers would come
along, grab a bunch of
tortoises, put them on the ship,
and then they would hunt
for whales or [inaudible].
And sometimes when they were done in the,
the ship was filled with Wale products.
Here they throw a few
extra tortoises overboard.
Say a few from Pinta, maybe those pins,
tortoises swam with occurrence to that
nearby island set up a little ex-pat
community
[inaudible]
and started breeding with the locals.
That's our working hypothesis,
which brings us to her idea.
Perfect.
You know,
on average 50% of your genome comes
from your mom and 50% from your dad,
but it's an average.
So just sell it though. Just by
chance, some of these tortoises,
they're gonna have a little bit more
Pinta DNA from their Pinta ancestors than
others. Yes. So what if
we took those tortoises
and bred them together?
So act them for the next generation so
that you can give a push to this process.
She says, if we keep doing this, taking
the babies with the most painted DNA,
breeding them together slowly,
surely in four generations you could
have 90% of the painter genome restored.
Really? Yeah. But
that's four generations
of tortoises, not rats,
which means at least a hundred
years. But in the meantime, the,
the vegetation on Pinta is growing out
of control from an ecological point of
view. Painter can't wait. So in
2009 they come up with a stop gap.
They take 39 tortoises raised in captivity
and they use them as placeholders.
They sterilize them and put them
on Pinta. [inaudible]. Yeah.
Well these are very purest sort of
visions. Okay. Yeah. They sterilize them.
39 of them should, they're just basically
the lawn mowers. They're not. Exactly,
and they put them on Pinto and
they're just chomping away right now.
They're living out their lives
really happily on Pinta, you know,
until the originals are ready.
Now Linda says in the end,
you don't actually need to do the full
aggressive for generation breeding thing.
You can just take the best
Pinta is tortoises you find
and put those on Pinto and you know,
over the next 200,000 years
they will evolve into a paint a tortoise
and it could be a bit different than
the past.
Paint a tortoise because evolution and
mutation and all of that doesn't occur
the same.
But eventually nature's going to take over
and they will evolve
into painted tortoises.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
is this the way that everybody who
works on the tortoises thinks about it?
This kind of deep time? I don't know.
I'm not sure many other
people think about that.
We'll be back in less than 200,000 years
am but we will be different when we
come back and we will stay tuned. Hi,
this is Emily calling from
rainy Vancouver, Washington.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the National Science Foundation
and by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information about Sloan at
www dot Sloan dot. [inaudible]
okay.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by swell
investing an impact investing platform.
You vote with your dollars
when you shop. Well,
what if you could do the same
when you invest with swell,
invest in high growth companies without
checking your values at the door.
It's a market opportunity linked to
global progress in clean water who are new
herbal energy medical breakthroughs.
Get a $50 bonus when you open your
account@swellinvesting.com slash Radiolab
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab today,
a whole hour on the Galapagos Islands.
The place that inspired Charles Darwin
to create his theory of evolution,
whose basic ingredients are lots of
time isolation and then constant change.
But Darwin didn't
consider this possibility.
What if on these islands,
thousands of tourists arrive every
day carrying fruits and chocolates and
souvenirs, jumping from island to island.
Now the Galapagos government spends
millions of dollars checking all of the
goods that come in and out trying to
quarantine the ones that might have things
that are a problem.
But what if simply putting your foot on
the ground can completely transform it?
A place that
[inaudible] active producer Tim Howard.
So I met this woman named Hunky Yeager,
who is a like a plant scientist.
I'm the restoration ecologist at
the Charles Darwin Foundation,
and here we are in Los Angeles.
We were going to look at these incredible
craters called low semi-loads. Oh,
I almost got hit by a car. And as we're
walking along the path, let's see.
She's like, oh wait,
look at this right here.
She points just to the right of the
path. Look at this species here.
Small leafy green thing. They
call it Yangton and Spanish.
It is in it's plantar ago,
I think in the u s they call it the,
um, was it the wrench of the white man?
The range of the white man? Yes. It's
actually the footprint of the white man.
It doesn't matter. Point is an
introduced species. It's introduced,
it's found in Europe. North
Africa shouldn't be here.
And you have this one here.
She points right next to it.
It's called Titus Canthia sharpie
thing. A green and white leaves.
It has a terrible common name in
English. I'm not going to say it.
Wandering Jew basic house plant.
You can buy it at home depot, but a,
there it is in the Galapagos.
And um, along this path,
just looking to the right and the left.
And then she just starts counting the
number of invasive species at one, two,
three, four. As you can see here,
it's only right next to the trail,
but not so much for them.
You see that they're only there for
this border of about to 10 inches
along the edge of that path. Why
would that be? Because hunky said,
what happens is it Taurus, they'll
be back in their home country,
there'll be walking around in a garden
or a park and it'll be filled with tiny
seeds. The seeds stick
tissues and socks and chowders.
They wear the trousers on a plane and
then they wear them when they come here,
and then people walk and then just
distribute or disperse the seats along the
trail. Wow.
Now most of these plants are actually
probably harmless and you know,
like you said, Galapagos National
Park, they spend tons of money,
tons of time trying to keep invasives out,
but the fact is there's only so much
you can do. And every once in a while,
one of these hitchhikers slips under
the radar and just wreaks havoc.
[inaudible]
you just grabbed it just like that.
You just put your hands around here.
That's the only possible the first day.
So while we were in the
highlands of Santa Cruz,
Hunky took me through the woods to meet
this guy named Arno. My name is Onecima.
Dom is an ornithologist from
the University of Vienna.
And shortly after we walked up,
he reached out into this tree and he
grabbed this tiny little baby fins right
off the branch is the door.
Well, he says, oh my God,
he said he, he looks a little bit
furry, almost really tiny vulnerable.
A fledgling of a, of finch. [inaudible]
is the smallest of the Darwin's finches.
You can like see him pulsing kind of as
he breathing. So Darwin's finches. Yeah.
In short, Darwin, when
he visited Galapagos,
he collected a lot of specimens of
finches, took them back to England,
and eventually he realized
that the beaks had all adapted.
They were all little bit
different depending on which
island the finches lived
on with the beaks. Beaks adapt to
whatever the thing is you're eating.
One islands finches had literally like
the beak would be shaped sort of long.
And then the next island it would
look almost the same but much shorter.
And this became one of the, one of the
most important pieces of evidence that,
you know, when animals would
move from one place to another,
that they would begin to differentiate
based on what cities are very,
very important things. Yes.
But speaking of beaks, that finch, that
Arno is holding, it's just the Fred,
his beak that you see the
specially decide is extremely huge.
Yeah. Oh, the nostrils. Nostrils
have have big holes. Yeah.
Something had gotten inside this little
finches, nostrils drilled these holes,
and it was no eating the flesh on
the inside of the birds nostrils.
Scientists first began to see this in
1997 when they started to find nests full
of dead baby finches. At first,
nobody had any idea what
kind of creature it was.
So they began to frantically study it.
I actually visited
one of the main researchers, PA
doddling Congo. I keep the name of
[inaudible]. She's lived in
Galapagos for over a decade.
And she showed me her lab.
I'm surrounded by shelves
and on the shelves there are
these tiny little plastic
cups that are filled with, um, flies.
This is the villain.
But I see say Solo [inaudible] a little
black fly looks like every other flies
is [inaudible]. In fact, P dot.
Says that it's actually in the same
family as the regular house fly,
but it's actually a bot fly
called the Lorena's down z.
Can you just spell fullness
down z? Yeah, it's p. H. I. L.
I can't spell out loud feel lore.
L. O. R. N. I. S. D. O. W. N. S. I.
Okay. Following this actually means,
but loving that Charlotte Coston,
she's a researcher at the Charles
Darwin Foundation. She says,
there's actually very
little known about the fly.
They're not sure where it came
from or quite how it got here,
but here's what they do know.
[inaudible]
the adult fly seems to be harmless,
yet a fly is actually vegetarian.
It feeds on flowers and we
think decomposing fruits,
baby flies. They're not vegetarian.
That will, you know, suck blood.
And what happens is that I'm, as
soon as bad start laying eggs,
mother flies swoop in and lay
their eggs on the base of the nest,
sort of underneath the finch
eggs. Once the eggs hatch,
the eggs hatch of the flies as well.
And the larvae wriggling little larva
will crawl out from the bottom of the nest
of the finches body into its beat.
And they go into the
noses and, um, of, uh,
of the baby finches and just started
eating. You know, they basically, um,
feed on the blood of the, the baby beds.
How did these little fly
babies? No, I mean, that's a,
that's a very specific trip
to take. Good question.
We're still trying to figure
that out. Um, you know,
we assumed that it was carbon dioxide,
carbon dioxide from the
breathing of the beds. Yeah.
She's opening a box of some
of the birds that little, um,
being sewn as the finches.
Oh God. It's the noise.
No to man.
Pa Dad showed me this, this tiny
little dead finch in the spa.
[inaudible] wow. There's a little hole
into the brain of this little finch.
Oh my God.
Wiggle in there and I spotted that they
ate the whole back of this little finch.
It's a, how big a problem is this? Well,
I talked to one scientist, Sonia Klein.
Dorfer, I'm professor in animal
behavior at Flinders University,
South Australia.
And she told only that researchers
recently did a survey of finch nest for
different species on two islands and
all research groups found about 95%
mortality in the nest.
95% of the babies were dead. Yeah.
And Arno told me that this
year, small tree finches.
So far we have only two
nests with fledglings and
all the others were on that.
So it's a lot. Yeah,
but even worse so far, we
found file on us on 39 islands.
The flies spreading island to island.
Is there any timescale
we should worry about?
Like are these finches disappearing
very fast? Very slowly.
Depends on the species.
We have at least five species that are
known to be facing extinction and another
six in serious decline.
These five species,
does that mean that they may go
extinct in the next five years,
in the next 50 years? I hope not.
Um, you know, we have the
case of the mangrove finch.
We have 60 to 80 individuals left. Wow.
It's a race against time.
[inaudible].
So for starters,
they put up all these tracks and
[inaudible] and they took me outside.
They showed me where the traps are.
A trap hanging from a tree here and you
see them actually all over Santa Cruz,
these bright yellow traps hanging from
trees. [inaudible] Lord in his own name.
But, and this is to control
the fly population? No, no, no.
They would need like millions of
drops every few feet to do that.
This is just to grab a few
flies, take them back to the lab
and study them so they can
learn how to fight him.
Charlotte and pay Dodd's fantasy is that
the flies use a pheromone to attract
the opposite sex CDO finally testicle.
It would be lovely if we could find
something like that because if they could
find that chemical, that love chemical
that the flies use to attract each other,
they could disrupt it, confused the
flies and screw up their mating.
And another possibility is
sterile insect technique,
sterilize male flies and introduce them
back into the wild so that the female,
I'm mates with a starer fly and
obviously doesn't produce fertile eggs.
If they can't make babies,
the population will crash.
And in some cases you can
successfully eradicate a species.
This is very much like the mosquitoes
that Andy talked about a couple podcasts
ago. Right. But here's the problem.
[inaudible] if they're gonna release
sterilize male flies into the wild,
they have to be able to
raise [inaudible] million.
These fires in the lab
[inaudible] and they're trying like
crazy showing me all of the larvas that
hatch today.
And that showed me four baby flies that
had just hatched and they're in these
Little Cup
[inaudible] but she told me that
these four flies will probably die.
Mm.
Because they always die.
Right now we have huge problems trying
rear file on this and captivity,
which is ironic given you know
how abundant it is in the wild
[inaudible] when I was there. Yeah.
That told me that so far they had
only successfully raised three,
$3 flies when you're saying
they needed millions. Yeah.
And meanwhile the finch populations
are just getting decimated.
Charlotte says that
they're trying to respond.
Ornithologists have started to notice
some new behaviors. For instance,
picking the Lafayette of the
nostrils of, of the baby birds.
And what we're starting to see is that
they're beginning to consume them.
You mean eat the fly lower? Yeah.
Which 15 years ago they would never do.
Back in the year 2000 Sonya and some
colleagues tried feeding the finches some
fly larva. And if ever there were
a look of disgust on a finch face,
that was it. So I think
there's been a change.
They're also seeing baby finches
climbing up over each other,
just struggling to get away from the
larva on the bottom of the nest. I'm,
and they'll even start standing on the
nest room just to avoid being eaten by
it. When I asked Charlotte what she
makes of all of these changes, she said,
um, I think probably too little, too late.
[inaudible]
but then Sonia told me something
really surprising. Yeah. That,
that was a very unexpected discovery.
Takes a couple steps to get there,
but just to set it up,
back in 2000 she was on Floriana island
for the first time I started studying
Darwin's finches in particular
three Trufant species, the small,
the medium and the large.
And we went out and we,
we set up our mist nets and we caught
the birds and we measured them.
And the thing to know is that even
though these are three different species,
they're actually really
hard to tell apart visually.
So she would end up relying on their
songs, their mating calls. Yep.
Do you remember the song types? Could
you whistle them for me? Oh yes. It's,
it's a very simple song. The small tree
finch goes something like two, two,
two two two two two
[inaudible].
That's a small tree finch and the,
the medium tree finch is just a
bit slower for the medium as a t,
t t t for the large g,
g G. G. Wow.
It's like a soprano saxophone in an
alto and the 10 or something like that.
That's right. So we, we just, you
know, sat in the forest and we're,
and we would always quiz each
other. What's that? What's that?
And we all agreed because the calls are
really distinct, easy to tell apart.
But the interesting thing was from
year to year, it got more difficult.
As Tony says, each time
she'd go into the field,
the song sounded like they
were starting to blur together.
Then when I showed up
after a few years, again,
I was truly even more
perplexed. Should I dad,
why can't I tell these finches
apart? It was very confusing.
Am I losing my touch? But
that shouldn't really happen.
You should actually get better
with experience. Not Worse.
And that's where I thought, oh,
something's changed in the system.
I like to think of it as a kind of,
um, Darwin finch, you know, slew thing,
adventure.
So Sonia and your team rounded up some
of the birds they tagged and we collected
genetic samples, got some DNA and song
samples, made some recordings. Yep.
Brought all this stuff into the lab,
analyze the genetic samples and had
this terrible realization that the large
tree finches now extinct.
[inaudible]
totally gone from the island. So you
really only had two species left.
You had the small tree finches
and the medium tree finches.
And based on that genetic data,
the small tree finches not doing great,
but compared to the medium tree finches
they are because the medium tree finches
were on the brink of extinction
like a large ones. Yeah.
But then she sees something
amazing in that genetic data.
She sees a small group of
birds who have mixed up genes,
a hybrid cluster,
some genes from the small tree finches
and some from the medium tree finches.
Huh? What does that mean? Well,
it means that these two different finches
had started having babies together,
which should never actually happen because
these are totally separate species.
That's really the classical definition
of a species is like a biological rule
about who you're not going
to make a baby with. So they,
they choose not to breed even
if they could for who knows,
maybe a million years. The medium tree
finch has patrolled that boundary. Like,
I've got my thing over here.
You got your thing over there.
But then along come the flies and all
of a sudden like over maybe 20 years,
these medium tree finches,
they start to break their own biggest
rule and they start to meet outside of
their own kind. And these hybrid finches,
are they doing better against
the flies? Well, there's,
there's a couple of clues that say maybe,
yeah. For example, when you look at
in the nest,
they seem to have fewer parasites and
they seem to have more babies that survive
15% wow.
Whereas the numbers were very small for
the medium tree finch and smaller for
the small tree finch. Wow. I dare
say that sounds kind of hopeful.
It does. Yeah. Now the jury is still
very much out on what will happen,
but if the hybrids do have a fitness
advantage and if they survive,
we may be witnessing in hyperspeed the
creation of an entirely new species.
It would possibly be one of the first
vertebrate examples of speciation in real
time that we can observe.
So talk to into the story of these finches
is the story of Galapagos.
Uh,
same exact story that Darwin saw.
These processes that you've described
[inaudible]
they just never ever stopped.
It's this [inaudible] ending
struggle.
[inaudible]
one last thing. My last night there,
I went to meet up with that Guy
Lonidas who was running for mayor.
I met him at this pizza place. The
election had happened the night before.
And did he win? No. A Buccellati
the incumbent one. So we,
we go outside. Chelonian [inaudible]
Paralis I was running as the mayor.
Turns out he speaks some
English. So we, you know,
we do this interview in English and I'm,
I'm almost embarrassed that I wanted to
talk to him because I think that dude is
just going to be so down and
out. Exactly the opposite.
He was so joyful to have lost. That's
what I thought. You're not sad.
You're not sad. Oh No. Never
Fred. And he's like, friend,
this is a field of four. The other
three all have money behind them.
And you see their flags all over Santa
Cruz. I just came in second. Whoa.
The guy who wins. He spent
$500,000 I spent what, two grand?
It's
the beginning. Is DV [inaudible] of a new,
a new future for the Galapagos island.
We are ascending and we
keep, we have our dreams up.
So nature has a boys. Now the
sea lion has a boys in us.
The tortoise as a Boise, not
the penguin in everywhere.
So something is happening.
That's exactly how he sees it.
So thank you very much for the interview.
I hope you enjoy the Galapagos island.
We call that the song
[inaudible]
producer Tim hour before we close.
Very special thanks to Matthew Judas
kilty without whom Tim have been crushed
just by the sheer amount of tape
that he gathered from deed. Also,
thanks to Dylan Key for original music.
Thanks to Trish Dolman and screen
siren pictures. Alex Galfond,
Mathias Espinosa, the naturals guide from
the first chapter who wrote this song,
peak open zone. He's also a well
known musician in Galapagos.
Turns out thanks to the
Galapagos National Park,
Charles Darwin Foundation
island conservation and
the Galapagos conservancy.
I'm Chan. I'm from Rod. I Robert
Krulwich. Thanks for listening.